avant d'être pincer le célèbre
narcotrafiquants el chapo a pu compter
sur l'aide d'une des plus grandes
institutions financières de la planète
la banque hsbc a aidé plusieurs cartels
mexicains à blanchir plus de 880
millions de dollars
hsbc a réussi à éviter des poursuites
pénales en signant un accord de
réparation et en promettant aux
autorités américaines qu'elles allaient
resserrer ses contrôles or voilà qu'une
nouvelle fuite d'informations ultra
secrète montre que la banque a continué
à transférer des fonds notamment pour
des fraudeurs notoire et des présumés
blanchisseurs d'argent russe pourtant
hsbc affirme être une institution
beaucoup plus sûre qu'elle ne l'était
auparavant l'affût des fines cette phase
a été obtenu par le site de nouvelle
beauce fille départager avec le
consortium international des
journalistes d' enquête et radio canada
on y trouve plus de 2100 déclarations
d'opérations douteuses signalés par les
banques auprès de fines scène l'autorité
de surveillance américaine l'échantillon
de la fuite qu'on plus de 2000 milliards
de dollars en fonds suspects des
déclarations qui ne sont pas
nécessairement une preuve d'activité
criminelles mais qui indique qu'il y a
un doute important
on y trouve aussi plus de 2400
transactions suspectes liés à des
sociétés ou à des institutions bancaires
canadiennes
le député fédéral charlie angus
s'intéresse aux questions sur la
criminalité financière depuis des années
les grands bec soir que le gouvernement
canadien
ce n'est pas intéressé mais enfin les
activités des bandits en cravate c'est
nécessaire pour le canada de menthe en
place les pénalités sévères
les documents révèlent qu'en ce qui
concerne les virements internationaux
les institutions financières ne savent
pas avec qui elles font affaire dans
près de la moitié des cas ce qui va à
l'encontre de leurs obligations
les vérifications effectuées par leurs
employés se limite souvent à de simple
recherche sur google
bien des institutions financières
signale des opérations douteuses mais
elles ne font rien pour les bloquer puis
en poche les frais bancaires
c'est légal et ça rapporte jusqu'à ce
qu'un scandale éclate ici frédéric zajac
radio canada vancouver